ni
みなさんこんにちは
城村と申します
まずは今日 tx 松本ようこそお越しくださいました
心で関係をいたしますありがとうございます
[拍手]
今日は
スピーカーの中で僕が
1人目へとなっています
今日朝のリハーサルの時にですねこの後登壇されます
後方野球の指導者中原監督に聞いたんですね
監督僕は今日一番なんですトップバッターなんですけども
トップがあったらやっぱりってどんなんですかって聞いたんです
そしたら監督がこう言ったんですそれはねその場を制圧するってことだよ
出てましたガーハート笑ってました
月火と言ってました
これから僕はこの場を制圧したいと思います
この後きっとなから監督もいろんな話をされると思いますが例えば高校野球
僕は今日1番バッターとしてここに立っています
クリーンなポーズ2
子どもたちもいればあるいはベンチの子
あるいはベンチにも入れず
スタンドで応援する子もいるかもしれません
社会にはいろんな役割があります
そしていろんなポジションを一人一人が求められています
その中で僕たちはどんなふうにしていけたらいいのか
地下力がある人だけが用いられてあるいは力がない人はイマイチだねって
僕はあまりそう思ってないんですねそれで今日はプロチュアな生き方ということでみな
さんにこの生き方を開いでお伝えしたいなってそんな風に思っています
まず僕の
働きの場を紹介します僕は実は教会の僕集をしているんですね
僕の職場こんなところです
長野県の駒ヶ根市その森の中に僕の強化あります
いいとこでしょとてもきれいなところです
ここで僕は牧師として仕事をしています
皆さん教会の牧師さんの仕事ってどんなイメージがありますかねえ
実は教会の牧師さんというのはいろんな人たちの話を聞くのがとても大切な仕事だっ
たりするんです
実は教会には男性も来れば女性もきます
あるいは
年老いた人もいれば若い人も健康な人もいれば病気の人もいます
いろんな人が来てそしてまたいろんな悩みを持ってくるんです
ある時こんな相談がありました夫婦で来たんです
とっても2人は悩んでました夫婦の中で
とても見過ごすわけにいかない大きな波の中でお互いに傷ついて
そして疲れきっていました
僕も牧師としてまた友人として彼らのそばで話を聞いていました
そして彼らを見送ってじゃ頑張ってネットを送った後その1時間後また別の夫婦が相談
に来たんです
2人も揉めてみました変化してたその理由なんだと思いますか
彼が言ったんです
ぽけさん俺はね彼女のティッシュの使い方が気に入らないんですよ
ティッシュをばかばかばかばか使うもんだから頭にきちゃってっていう
問題をそれぞれ違うんだけどもそれぞれの夫婦が悩んで苦しんでたりする
でも僕の立場から言うと
それはまだいいんですね
までいいんです実は彼らと向かい合っていくときに一番僕が気になることそれは何かと
いうと
これなんです自己肯定感
健全な自己愛を持てない人たちがたくさんいるということです
人と争っているうちはまだいいんですでも皆さん仲良くしましょう
ぜひ仲良くしてくださいでも
人と争ってるじゃんまだいい
それが自分自身に向かってきたときに人はものすごく大きな木ゾーンです
どうせ俺なんてどうせ私なんて
生きてる価値存在している員もないって
彼らはそんな風にして嘆くんです
そして深い悲しみの涙を流しています
彼らと迎えあっていく中で
僕が
友人としてまた牧師としてどんなふうにして迎えあってたらいいのか
どんな言葉をかけたらいいのかいつも悩んできました
そんな中で僕が彼らにお伝えをしていることそれがまさにこのプロ地はという1型なん
です
プロチュアとは何かそれは
プロフェッショナルとアマチュアの造語です
社会にはたくさんの素晴らしい技術を持った方がいいます
素晴らしい能力を持った方がいますそしてそういった方々は社会の中でリーダーとして
素晴らしい働きをしています
でも
そうじゃない人がほとんどです
では
プロでない人すごい技術やすごい能力を持ってない人が
存在する意味がないんでしょうか
アマチュアて全然ダメなんでしょうか
僕はそう思わないんですねいやむしろ
世の中アマチュアだけです
ある分野ではすごいプロフェッションなどだと言われている人ある分野では
すごい職人さんだって言われてる人でもその人たちもお家に帰れば
夫としてはアマチュアだったりします
母親としては町が立ったりします
いずれにしても私たちはすべての領域でプロフェッショナルであるということはでき
ないんですね
そしてアマチュアである中で僕たちは生きていかなければいけない
僕はプロチュアっていうのはこんな風にして考えています
どちゃは知っているんです何を知っているかと言うと
自分自身の不足や欠けを知っているんです
自分が
どんなことができないのか
あるいは自分自身の足りてない能力
不足しているもの自分自身の賭けというものをプロチュアは知っています
そしてプロチャーは尽くすんです
何を作るのか
それは自分自身に与えられた責任そして自分自身に与えられている
能力
そこに責任を果たしていくんです
そして自分自身ができうる限りの最善を尽くしていく
それがプロ地はだということです
ですので僕の考えているプロちょっとこういうことなんです
できるか否かではなくて最善を尽くす生き方なんです
僕は中学2年生の時に僕の人生を変える生成との出会いがありました
曲実習の先生でした
この先生は
実習の最後の避妊1時間僕たちの前だったんです
自由に使っていいと言われたそうです
曲実習の先生僕らに言いました
実は今日この1時間どうな牛節操したらいいんだろうって
今日ずっと朝まで眠れませんでした
僕は
他の先生方ね上手に語ることもできなければ
楽しい時間過ごせてあげることもできないだからもしも退屈だったらみんな寝てても
いいからねって
行ったんです
中学2年生の僕です
やったぜって言いました
生意気な少年でした
僕は
こんな態度をとりました
先生のその言葉を真に受けて僕はねたんです
ゲーム new と寝たふりをしていました
なぜ僕が寝たふりをしてたのか
それは
先生がまっすぐに僕たちに対して語ってきたらです
全然上手じゃありませんでした話は全然面白くなかったです
どんな内容だったのか僕は全く覚えていません
でも
この若い先生が大学生です教育実習のこの先生が僕たちに対してまっすぐに
メッセージを語ってきたんです
僕はその先生の姿を持った時に
しまった
いました
なんてことをしてしまったんだろうって
とっても恥ずかしかったんです
でも多感な中学生
中学2年生の僕ですとてもやったぜーと言って寝てしまった以上
頭を上げることができなかったんです
結局僕は
1時間その家がないだ
をで香机につけたまま圧後しました
そして先生が
どんな表情でその教室を後にしたのか
僕はその先生の顔を見ることができませんでした
心の中でずっと先生ごめんってここの中でずっと謝り続けれました
僕はプロチュアっていう生き方を思ったときにその原点をまさにここなんです
あの先生は
本当に話上手じゃなかったんです下手くそでした
なっても面白くなかった
でも
すぐに
技術位
自分自身がやるべきことを語るべきことを語ってくれたんです
先生のあの時の言葉
声思いっていうのを僕は忘れることができないんです
私たちは一人ひとりが
それぞれの家計を持っています
私たちは消しスーパーマンではありません
いろんな不足足りなさを持っていますでもその中で
僕たちは生きていかなければいけません
誰かと比べて負けた
誰かと比べて買った
そういう着方ではないんです
かけがあっていいんです
誰なくていいんです
あなたがあなたであること
あなたがあなたであることに全力であってほしいんです
それが
プロでもないアマチュアでもない
プロ中はという第3の生き方なんです
今から数年前
2011年この国に大きな災害が起こりました
東日本大震災です
その時に私たちは一人ひとり
自分たちにできることを考えました
そして自分にできることを
いたはずです
ある人は物資を被災地に送りました
ある人が自分自身がボランティアと言ってしてその現場に駆けつけてきました
我が家でも子供たちと話をしたんです
さあ僕たちに何ができるだろう
そしたら小学校1年生だった長男が僕にこう言ったんです
馬場
僕をリサイクルショップに連れてって欲しいって
そう言った彼の手には彼の宝物 box があったんです
その中に何が入ってるか僕は知っていました
息子連れて僕は
街にあるリサイクルショップに行きました
そして彼は
その店で
自分がそれまでお小遣いやあるいはお年玉で貯めた
カードおもちゃのパックをお店に売ったんです
オフィスノブさんがとっても心配していました本当にこれを打っていいの
全部無くなっちゃうけどだいじょぶっ
息子は大丈夫だよって全部買ってくださいっ
これを打った
その金額は
¥1,678でした
立ったの¥1,678です
でも息子は本当に嬉しそうだったんです
そのなぜかというとお店のおばさんが取っても褒めてくれたんです
すごく褒めてくれたえらいねってすごいねって
僕たちを役はこの¥1,678を握りしめて近くのコンビニに行きました
そしてそのレジ横にある募金箱に
お金をしたんです
何ができますか
果たしてこの金額でどれだけの人を救うことができるでしょうか
本当に限られたものだと思います
でも
この子にとっては
これは精一杯だったんです
わずか1678へ
美味しいものを食べていたこともできないでしょう
あるいは被災者のがれきを片付けることができないでしょう
道路を作ることも足をかけることもできないと思います
でも
こんな小さな子どもが
自分にできる
一杯を尽くしていったんです
プロちゅ後はまさにそういうことなんです
人と比べて
勝ってるとかをとっているとか
嬉しいとか悲しいとかそういうことではないんです
あなたが
あなたであること
自分にできることに最善を尽くしてくる
生き方なんです
人と比べなくていいんです
自分自身の足りなさがあったとしても
手足があったとしても
それを受け入れていくんですいいんですそこがあっていっ
その上で
自分にできることを
最善を尽くして
プロチャーわー
社会をつくっていきます
そしてそんなプロチャーが増えていくと社会は変わるんです
決して社会をつくっていくのは一部の人市ではありません
どこかの頭のいい人どこから凄い技術を持った人すごいプロフェッショナル
彼らが社会を作ってるんじゃないんです
社会をつくっているのは私たちです
社会をつくるのはあなたなんです
他の誰でもない
あなたが
あなたであることに
全力を尽くしてほしいんです
自分の足りなさや不足を全て受け入れてほしいんです
でもその中で
自分にできることを精一杯最善を尽くして生きていただきたいんです
僕はこのプロ地はな生き方が増えていくことを心から願っています
プロフェッショナルも素晴らしいですぜひ目指してください
アマチュアもいいでしょうでも第3の生き方です
プロチャーとして生きるということ
ぜひあなたの生き方を通して
あなたの人生を通して
あなたの精一杯の最善を通して
あなたと出会う人が本当に幸せであることになっています
そしてそんなプレッシャーとして生きるあなたの力によって
この社会がもっともっと良いものとなっていくことを心から来て期待をしています
ぜひともにプロチャートして生きていきましょう
ありがとうございました
[拍手]